let's talk about the uh the steele
dossier man so we have this story from
the washington post and this is a little
bit more in the weeds on on the on on
the politics but this is really really
important so for those that are just
tuning in or who are not familiar with
what's going on with the steele dossier
and the derm investigation i'll put it
simply for years there were lies from
democrats and the media about trump
colluding with russia
none of it was true and now it looks
like people are actually the people who
perpetrated the hoax for years are
starting to get charged and so we have
this story from the washington post
indictment of steele dossier source is
more bad news for multiple media outlets
let me just break this down very simply
for those that may not understand the in
the wheat stuff the media lied they're
caught political operatives lied they're
caught politicians lied and got caught
and cash you have a lot of information
about this man yeah so look the steele
dossier and i don't think i've ever
actually told anyone this but when i was
running the russiagate investigation for
chairman nunes initially the media
wanted to call it the the
trump dossier and i said no no no we're
going to call it the steele dossier so
because i said this thing is fraudulent
so if you're going to tie it to someone
to tie it to the author and we change
the narrative real quick in the early
days and it stuck
wow and uh i never told that to anybody
um and so look i can go on and on about
the russia gate hoax i spent two years
of my life living it and then getting
validated by the ig and now this
basically if you want to know what
happened watch the plot against the
president we're in it it's super easy to
watch and understand if you want to get
up to speed on russia gate the steele
dossier is the heart of russia gate what
happens
the democrats and the hillary clinton
campaign go out and pay a foreign
national christopher steele of retired
british spy to go and get dirt from
russia against then-candidate trump the
problem is christopher steele hadn't set
foot in russia in 20 years fact
then we're like wait wait a second who
paid for all this oh hillary clinton
they paid the law firm who was also
previously indicted just before this one
perkins coie 10 million dollars
so now you have the political campaign a
political operative as you said and the
lawyers now
teaming up together with fraudulent
information what do they do with that
they don't just dump it in the media
that would have been one thing to go
after your opponent and just dirty them
up in usual political tricks they take
the fbi and the doj and they hijack the
surveillance process and they basically
say here's this information from this
guy we're not going to present the court
the judge with all of it we're going to
give you pieces of it we're going to
keep exculpatory in information of
innocence out we're going to prevent the
court from hearing who paid for it and
that it went to hillary clinton and her
lawyers and then we're going to go
surveil a presidential candidate because
that's what we want to do
they they ultimately
they they didn't impeach him on
russiagate but they ukraine ukraine gate
was and that was insane too but for the
russia stuff so this this article we
have from the washington post is from
eric wempel he's a media critic and he's
been doing a really good job
going after the media for their
malpractice for the malfeasance it's
shocking that he is i know i know yeah
yeah this is the washington post this is
this is democracy dies in darkness but
uh he recently did a story about joe
rogan and iver mechton and he was like
cnn's acting like an advocacy like
activist organization by lying about
this stuff so i'm not i don't want to
rehash i want to bring all that stuff up
just yet we're talking about you know
russiagate and stuff but he opens right
away by saying msnbc host rachel maddow
december 2017 aired a special report on
the trump-russia dossier compiled by
former british intelligence officer
christopher steele the document claimed
mata relied on information coming from
steele's deep cover sources inside
russia a federal indictment unsealed
thursday has something to say about the
quality of those sources it charges igor
d'anchenko the dossier's primary
intelligence collector with making false
statements to the fbi about his
interactions with sources consulted for
the dossier
when trump first got elected
there was a guy who tweeted we're going
to impeach him remember remember the
name do you remember his name oh man it
was probably one of the lawyers no no it
was one of the lawyers on ukraine i
remember that okay yeah yeah yeah so
we're not allowed to say the name of the
whistleblower in that case just so you
know that youtube will delete the video
i won't say it isn't that insane
that's censoring but but let's let's
let's let's you know we'll get to the
heart of of what this is russiagate was
was for how many years of lying five
years of line five we're on five and and
and here's the thing and you're right
the reason this article is so important
is who's christopher steele who cares
about this guy he got paid all this
money he was just doing dirty tricks for
a political party okay fine one thing
where did he get all this information
from this guy
they are now saying the washington post
is now admitting based on durham's
indictment special accounts indictment
that the mountain of information that
the source steele got from his primary
guy in russia was total bs totally
fraudulent so their entire investigation
they the fbi's entire investigation just
got gutted and if i can juxtapose two
things right
this washington post article and we all
know who david ignatius is he wrote a
hit piece on me three months ago on the
cover of the washington post he wrote a
hit piece on me because he knew the
russia gate conspiracy was unraveling we
had proven it to be defective so what
does he do headline chief investigator
for russiagate is possibly leaking
classified information to the media so
now i get a wave of media hits coming at
me the next day not just in america but
overseas saying cash patel leaks
classified information this is what they
do so it's shocking to me that the
washington post would let this ride but
i'm happy that they did you would think
there would be some repercussions for
lying through their teeth
and and just admitting so many important
facts i remember looking at this story
from the very beginning being like uh
okay
intelligence agents sources say
government sources say i'm like where's
the evidence where's the documents
where's any photos where's any document
where's anything that proves that this
is legitimate i was like there's nothing
here i call bunk i don't believe this
the intelligence agencies have lied
before and they they kept saying well
there's 17 intelligence agencies there's
17 of them i'm like i don't believe any
of this and i got called a crazy
conspiracy theorist i got listed by the
washington post as a russian asset as
working for the russians by the way i'm
polish
for polish people they get very offended
when they get compared to russians but
the washington post literally listed my
news organization we are change as a
russian asset organization because i
wasn't buying the official story and not
only did they lie through their teeth
about everything they attacked anyone
who even dared question it they wrecked
lives it's a cult
okay so i see the memes all day with
like trump's colt and trump's cult and
i'm like yeah yeah but is trump's cult
at the washington post writing fake news
for five years yeah trying to get people
impeached and ruining people's lives i'm
sorry man you get a bunch of people
showing up at the grassy knoll or
whatever thinking jfk jr is coming back
it has no impact on our federal level
politics it was a couple hundred people
i don't know why i should care about
that when the media when when abc when
when cnn when washington post in the new
york times when they're winning pulitzer
prizes for making up fake news
are they going to get that retracted are
they going to get that prize rejected
rescinded whatever probably not
you know what scares me the most about
this story is how
absolutely devastating it is
how it contributed to the political
divide as it worsens today and how it's
very difficult to understand let me let
me follow up with two things one in 2017
now everybody's like cash trump's
right-hand man whatever do you know when
i i had not met president trump spoken
to him campaign for him i was a career
government guy so the two years i ran
russiagate i didn't have never spoken to
the man nor communicated with him i just
ran an investigation now now in
retrospect they're saying kash patel was
president trump's best you know best
friend running the russiagate
investigation it's pretty hard to do
when you've never met the man now the
other thing that you brought up that i'd
like to highlight is the lives that were
wrecked
and i'll leave the names out of it we
interviewed 60 a lot of witnesses one
individual a father right had a he had
to
he had to utilize his entire life
savings just for lawyers because he got
called into the committee by adam schiff
to testify about nothing meaningful
his daughter relapsed
a
recovering drug addict relapse because
of the coverage her father received in
the media
and went into a downward spiral and
almost died he then had to take a second
mortgage on his house to pay for his
daughter's rehab jeez man
that's reality yo i think adam schiff is
an evil guy he's i mean don't get me
started on that guy he's evil can i ask
what was happening in the intelligence
agencies because we kept hearing 17 of
them all agree they're all on board they
know there was russian collusion 100 and
that's the headline that was running in
the mainstream media everyone was still
looking for evidence but they were
running with it like like it was just
the truth from god uh what was happening
because there was no pushback at all
that i've seen from any of these
intelligence agencies to be like hey hey
uh actually we don't have nothing here
yeah so it didn't come till halfway
through trump's term when we shifted
around leadership in the intelligence
community but in the beginning the first
two years you basically had a willing
media like you're talking about and adam
shift and people like that were leaking
classified information to say well we
can't get into the details but trump
colluded trump had a p party the
envelope trump did this the envelope
reading the steele dossier into
congressional testimony as if it was the
bible you know just things like that and
you get your headlines and the media
gets their headlines and they all wanted
to take out donald trump so
didn't they claim that he like peed on a
bed in a hotel or something you want to
know something hilarious about that so i
said you know i was talking to devin i
said look we got to do two things as a
friend it was a former prosecutor follow
the money somebody paid for this thing
let's go get bank records which is how i
was able to prove fusion gps and the
clintons paid for all this right and
they wanted to crucify me when i took
him to federal court but the other thing
is i said look this guy this is pretty
crazy trump's having sex parties in
russia
like
i don't know that you can get away with
it without a lot of people finding out
so let's call the hotel i call the hotel
the hotel does not have that
presidential suite that this infamous
christopher steele this career spy
slotted into his theodosia i said if the
if the hotel room doesn't even exist do
you think the rest of this dossier has
credibility this guy can't even get the
hotel room right hmm
are we right
it's crazy there's nothing there's
nothing there and then this is this
should tell you the
huge amounts of lies that the government
along with some intelligence agencies
some people within it along with the
mainstream media could all in unison
work together to fool
everyone because everyone was buying
they didn't fool you well yeah but then
they ostracized and attacked anyone who
wasn't who wasn't buying the official
story and then this was one of the
reasons why wikipedia censored me and
de-personed me on their platform it was
because of that washington post article
that said i was a russian asset which i
wasn't i mean there was no evidence
suggesting this at all and it was just
smear-mongering
by smear merchants who get off at
ruining people's lives
but but for a journalist who was around
at that time all you have to do is ask
some questions being like okay let's
let's actually find out what really
happened here and and and let's barely
any people did that let's let's talk
about uh uh we'll advance from here talk
about ukraine gate
so this is where they actually impeach
donald trump with the lies about ukraine
and the crazy thing was i was tracking
the news i was looking at european news
sources i was looking at the history of
the founder of barisma this is the
company where hunter biden the
president's son was a board member and
my conclusion on this was like okay
first i'm i entertained russiagate you
know like i'm just like reading the news
i'm like wow this is crazy stuff i
actually met with one of the most
high-profile russiagate journalists and
asked them like
to to their face looked in their eyes do
you think trump actually did this and
they're like without a doubt he did and
i was like wow and i'm like i'm in a bar
with one of these like you know
mainstream media journalist telling me
like bro we have the proof i've seen it
i'm like wow it's all fake
so then you create ukraine gate comes
along and this is where you know trump
apparently sees a video on twitter of
joe biden being like if you want the hey
you got to fire the prosecutor so trump
just was like i wonder what that's about
i'm not i'm not necessarily trying to
rehash ukraine gate but to point out you
end up with these journalists like matt
taibbi yeah formerly of rolling stone a
real journalist and he's a liberal guy
yeah and all of a sudden now he's an
alt-right grifter and same with aaron
mate yeah right aaron mata he's a
progressive yeah he i've done both those
guys i've interviewed both both those
guys done podcasts with both those guys
we could not be more politically opposed
to each other but there used to be a
time when you could be a real journalist
as you're talking about and if there's
corruption or illegality you would call
it out if it was right or left those are
seem to be the only guys on the left
that want to do it anymore thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time